Gregory is in Illinois hi Gregory how
are you thanks for taking my call Dave
sure how can I help
here's why I'm in your program when you
hear what I did you probably kill me
haha okay Merry Christmas
very good YouTube what you doing wife
already had so what'd you do
well I did I was a nice guy I thought
alone a cold sign of water-ice son of a
friend of mine back in January 2016
guess what happened he didn't pay the
bill that's why it was so what happened
Wells Fargo is is a bank yeah they have
not they have not paid that all for
three times my question to you I've got
two loans on mortgage payment and that's
it chai chai you get that money and put
on a loan so I hit play Wells Fargo all
that interest by the way my credit bled
out from 607 4006 40 what shall I do
yeah well see here's a problem you
weren't actually a nice guy if you
actually help the kid get into something
that ruined the kid's life too and
wasn't nice at all
was it so yeah you're right those
knucklehead you're right hey baby
so you are so you've learned your lesson
on co-signing I guess you'll tell you
tell your grandkids this story right I'm
on them plan damn Dave November 2007 pn3
I'm good for you baby yeah until you got
this okay that blows your heart I'm
sorry
well um yeah the boy and don't pay it
it's gone the car got repo'd and they
have a deficit balance that Wells Fargo
sitting on right yes they try to sell
for three times David I haven't sold it
I tried to settle sell the debt the car
well he's got the cars already gone
I mean I'd call out their color Idol and
they will not they will not let me talk
to a certain person I that's between
them in Wells Fargo and talk to two
attorneys and uh no goes so far so I'm
calling you to give me some
I know I had to pay the debt okay I'm
gonna make one do my lawyer said settle
I thought you said sale so you've tried
to talk to them three different times to
settle the debt and have been unable to
yes sir yes okay but you've got have you
gotten any word I mean you can at least
get a payoff balance no they haven't
sold a truck yet out there they haven't
they tried three times to sell the truck
and I calling them back and let them try
resell the truck at November 21st and
and they haven't done that yet so I
haven't got the difference yet I was
going to going to the bank and put the
put loan but that difference on alone
which I had to get myself out of Wells
Fargo that's yeah well you until you
have until they sell it they can't
establish the difference and until they
establish the difference you can't
settle that difference now probably your
house are upside down do you think this
truck is I'd say 19,000 no 2007 El
Dorado about 19,000 he paid about a
thousand so it's 118 thousand I figure
if they sell ever talked about all 6,000
okay all right and you probably can
probably settle that for two or three
thousand bucks how do you do that how do
you get them to come back well date but
all you got to do is talk to him about
it let's go you know that cuz you're not
they're not letting the kid off the hook
they're just letting you off the hook
I'm a cosigner I'm ready to write you a
check from my part today for $3,000 oh
we don't do that oh yeah my financial
counselor says you do and I'm your
financial counselor I just said they do
they settle it for any they settle them
for quarter on the dollar every day
because most the time they're never able
to collect the deficit balance because
most people go bankrupt alright and
you're not going to do that you're going
to settle with them on for something but
I don't think you're going to pay them
in full I think you're just going to
negotiate a settlement of some kind
you're going to get it in writing and
then yeah you're going to go borrow that
amount and pay off that's that $2,000 or
$3,000 or whatever you end up settling
this for and that's going to be a new
debt on your balance sheet and then
you'll be done with Wells Fargo here's
the thing you're trying to get this done
and you're dealing with people who don't
care
see what's what you're thinking is this
is money out of your pocket so you're
emotionally involved the guy you're
talking to on the phone hates his job he
has a job you're asking him to work he
doesn't want to work and so you're
you're speeding this up you're going to
have to wait until about March before
the smoke clears and the and this thing
gets down into their bowels of Wells
Fargo before you can get actually get a
hold of a person that can settle this
deal you're trying to run it on you help
you that do what I need an attorney of
happy with that no not when you get down
there just wait until March and then
talk to them and but they don't even
have the deficit balance established yet
because they've not sold the truck
exactly when they sell the truck that's
when they'll know what it brings and and
what the difference is and then there
they'll know what to come after you and
the boy for and then then then and only
then if you got something to negotiate
on and that you know believe me here's
the thing okay November 21st you know
what happened right after that
Thanksgiving you know what happened
right after that Christmas Translation
no bankers are working they don't work
right they don't work in December
they're all sitting around going to
parties and they don't give a rip it's
not their money Wells Fargo has eight
bazillion employees and most of them
don't work they don't they don't give a
rep and so where anybody would do
business with them is beyond me to start
with but anyway you you know that that's
what you're dealing with you're dealing
with people that don't give a rip
because it's not their money if it was
my money I'd be trying to collect it and
I'd be wanting to talk to you if it was
your money you'd be trying to collect it
right yeah
but we're like actual human beings you
know we're not just bankers and right so
so I mean it's just their job they don't
care that's what it comes down to so
anyway just just let it let the dust
settle out after the first year
somewhere around the 1st of March call
them up again
I think you'll probably find something
else is going on you don't need to get
in the big hurry here
you'll get it cleared up when you get it
cleared up and you've learned your
lesson
and you never cosign never ever ever
cosign for anyone for anything
ever ever ever I've co-signed for two
loans I paid them both one got cosign
for me before I went broken he ended up
paying the nine to go back and pay him
back I've never been around co-signing
is just I mean I've done it it's just
stupid on steroids so I mean you're just
you cosign for some little kid to get a
truck a $19,000 truck I mean good lord
you know I mean but we've all done it
man we've all done stupid I mean every
one of us have done stupid that's why we
all gather around the microphone here
celebrate not doing stupid anymore and
you won't ever do that one again do good
for you you learned your lesson it's a
painful lesson called experience it's a
it's a thorough teacher though that
master called experience this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you
[Music]